على بعد امتار من هذا الموقع كان زعيم
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي على
موعد مع هجوم قيل انه تركي هجوم ارادت
انقره من خلاله قول الكثير
الانتهاكات مستمره في العراق وسوريا ولها
ابعاد خطيره ضد المنطقه موقف الاتحاد
الوطني القومي المساند لاشقائه في سوريا
يزعج تركيا
الهجوم استهدف موقعا قريبا من مكان وجود
مظلوم عبدي اثناء توجهه الى مطار سليماني
عقب اجتماع جمعه بالامريكيين وقياده
الاتحاد الوطني الكردستاني في مقر مكافحه
الارهاب في السليمانيه
وفقا لمصادر العربيه الخاصه فان الهجوم
كان تحذيريا ولم يهدف الى التخلص من عبدي
الذي كان على متن مروحيه وبرفقه شخصيات
امريكيه امر حال دون استهدافه المباشر
بحسب مديريه امن مطار سليماني فان الهجوم
حدث عبر طائره مسيره وتسبب بانفجار قرب
سور المطار ولم ينتج عنه اصابات
هجوم يعيد الى الاذهان سيناريو مشابها في
الاسلوب والسلاح وعلى ارض عراقيه وان
اختلفت الشخصيات والنتائج رائد المصطفى
العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات